[Music]
when I was racing something that I brew
to really enjoy and value about what I
did was that I was able to inspire
people that's a powerful job to have and
so at the end of my career I thought man
what am I going to do so that I can
continue to inspire people
I'm Danica Patrick and I'm pretty
intense I believe that each and every
one of us has the power within ourselves
to create the life that we really want
and I want to help give you the tools to
make that happen that's why I created
this podcast we can learn together with
intense discussions about life-changing
ideas and ultimately realize our true
best self I want to help peel away the
layers that tough outer shell that we
develop as we get older and get to the
real root of why we do what we do and
what we're really feeling and why we're
feeling it and what we really want out
of this life I want to inspire you to go
conquer your dreams both professionally
and personally this podcast is for
people who are willing to stretch
themselves willing to try a little
harder oiling to put in the work and
someone who really wants something
they've never had so you're gonna have
to do something you've never done
the guests are gonna fall into all kinds
of facets of life they're gonna be
family they're gonna be friends they're
gonna be celebrities they're gonna be
musicians artists experts and
entrepreneurs we're gonna cover a myriad
of topics from health and wellness to
dreams and fears we're gonna go as deep
as we can possibly go with people we're
gonna dive into all of the facets of
their life whether they be what they do
what they eat how they feel what they're
interested in
sometimes people haven't necessarily
been asked a certain question or maybe
someone hasn't thought a certain way or
or even challenged themselves and I feel
like for me I got that therapy through
interviews so this podcast is going to
be intense therapy join me for this deep
dive but my only warning is to get
pretty intense
[Music]